genetics helps us understand the
biological programming behind all
life-forms but what exactly is the
science of genetics and what does its
future hold genetics is the study of
heredity the expression of traits and
how they are passed from generation to
generation for thousands of years humans
have observed this inheritance of traits
and implemented their knowledge to breed
and domesticate plants and animals
however the science behind inheritance
was only starting to be understood in
the mid 19th century around 1865
Austrian monk and botanist Gregor Mendel
published the results of his
hybridization studies of pea plants in
his findings he noted the role of
factors that influence the expression of
traits these factors later became known
as genes each human has between 20,000
and 25,000 genes this collection called
a genome determines a person's traits by
influencing factors on a cellular level
genetic information is stored in every
cell's nucleus structures called
chromosomes carry this information in
the form of deoxyribonucleic acid or DNA
DNA is a double helix of nucleotides
chemical compounds composed of sugar and
phosphate molecules along with the bases
by mean adenine guanine and cytosine
these segments of DNA are what we call
Gene's and it is within those genes that
chemical compounds provide the coding
for all information about a person's
inherited traits
human cells contain so much DNA to carry
this large amount of information that if
unraveled the DNA in each cell would be
over 6 feet long at the turn of the 21st
century an international effort to
decode human DNA was launched called the
human genome project it ended up
identifying about 99 percent of the
entire human genetic sequence a
revolution in medical science whose
implications far surpass even the
discovery of antibiotics discoveries in
genetics research have unearthed
tremendous opportunities in medicine
such as genetic testing in the
manipulation of genes but with these
opportunities come risks and ethical
questions and finding the answers to
those questions may be the next stage of
our understanding of genetics
[Music]
you